[Music]
hi welcome to insane an endgame I have a
bunch of puzzle prepared that are
supposed to be very dynamic but it looks
very fun to me so I hope you enjoy
finding the right answers to these and
I'll try to keep up with the chats and
read the comments and to be able to have
a nice pace not too fast not too slow so
let's dive in this is the first position
it's black to move and what would you do
I'm working on it I have a really
horrible Wi-Fi
mmm
ah I see
so I'm yeah perfect
bunch of our people saw rooks d1 perfect
yeah so the basic idea is you were gonna
play rook to e1 if take h2 and voila
whoops sorry
okay this one blacks are off
okay I'm getting ideas with Bishop b7d
five and rook up six
I'm gonna say it them off in about 10
more seconds
if you want instead of just one movers
you can give me more than one move and
we can think about it so if you're
saying
for example D five keep going say if
okay when the pond takes what do you do
next
if the pond doesn't take and like I take
the rook then what do you do
okay so I have a line of d5 CD 585 if
the King takes the rope 94 okay I agree
with that
but what if t5 take take the King takes
what do you do next
okay yeah cool there should be six if
you take over here what do you do
check if you take over here I mean if
you just go back check you win the queen
of King d6 check win great next one
again blacks you move
Tracy
comments
yeah some of the our online audience
found the right move should I say it
take it mate
think about the checks always think
about the checks because if you miss the
check you're gonna miss the meet
okay this one is also pretty interesting
it might look slightly weird so don't
beat yourself up if you can't find it
cuz it's o hint it's not a check
um Kim last what if Bishop g6 rookie 7
well right now you're a piece up so in
47 at least and your pieces are none of
your three pieces that are under attack
are going to be taking the next move
because the ricany 7 is kind of hanging
so
yeah always count the pieces first
well I mean the root key seven is
possible I mean if you want to play
Bishop g6 you should definitely think
about rookie seven just because that's
one of the viable moves but it's not
necessarily the only move well okay
first of all if you're for those of you
who are thinking about Bishop g6 think
about take back first and if not take
back then the rook has to move so then
think about if the rook moves where do
you want to take like how do you want to
play if the rook black rook for BH moves
away
and Gary Wright was also right so a
piece of g6 rookie 795 and if Bishop
takes to the night you take back with
the bishop and the e5 pawn is is still
pinned so this pawn is pants can't
really take it girls attacking so if
take take it's still pinned and you
can't take so so yeah now think about
what it take back what it take the
bishop and if not take the bishop then
where the row can go
okay so I don't know how to say this
chinnu 42 I'm trying okay thank you
he's right yeah ken is also right so if
take we agree I'll take and just take
this guy and just move the night
somewhere and just put it back so what
if not take what if let's say whoops
Roxy eight
so the problem is if you take on e5 well
I mean it's not that much of a problem
you should still be able to do that but
now you have to I mean I think this
should be good enough too because if
take take this should still you should
be good with this but there is a move
that seems better knight c6 and
basically you take take where do you
want to put their work here
now go shove f7 this is a cleaner win
what about the focus goes to b8 so nice
a six doesn't really work anyways
because there's this rook c8
so nice of you to join us Joseph still
bigger
yeah ken is right just take the pawn if
the night goes to g4 take the other pawn
and they take this piece yeah this
wasn't as as entertaining as the last
one but you guys did well proud all
right next one it's white to move again
I mean they're having pieces more and no
compensation for opponents should be
good enough that's still about the last
position
so I saw I read stuff about mate with
turkishwin
which is possibly true in one of the
variations but it's not as a straight
forward so if you take understanding
right now it's not as a straight forward
so you have the right idea just not the
exact okay Paul found one of the lines
so now think okay so you found if Brooke
e5 d5 you found the mates great what if
Luke takes e5 rook takes the knight
because that tonight is the problem
that's going to give the check on g6
right so
so we said whoops we said it'd take
night
what about take if you take on e5 to
take back on f4
Paul was right again rook the rook e8
Africa f8 and Bishop c4 Weiss wins
whatever fruit a rook e8 King moves up
yeah okay Paul is right again so Paul
was right to hope I love this puzzle
yeah you just get the piece happy ending
all right perfect next one this one is
black to move
so it's good that you guys are thinking
about checks the first but in this
specific situation
after you're done thinking there are
checks maybe think about takes and after
you're done with that thank you watch
moves with threats
so yeah Julian has a nice idea of night
f3
now just think about if that idea works
so yeah Brian which if the King goes to
giannios line of trees mates but if
Bishop g2 what if Knight takes on g2
so yeah I keep thinking give up the
first one of my to f3 idea and see if
that works
okay so yes Knight f3 is threatening
mate but if you play Knight f3 okay if
the Queen takes you take me but right
now if it was black to move again black
can't really take on here cuz Queen is 2
and it defends so whoops so right now
after Knight f3 was the best move for
white
well not exactly because even giving up
the Queen won't help
so Elias talks about mission efore yeah
mission before is the move to think
about so maybe think about that
yes Bishop e4 is the best move for
whites supposedly now how do you mate
yeah meanwhile found it perfect
good job
ready for next one
this one's white this one isn't that
hard it's just material stuff
yeah Paul found this good job
now if anybody wants to give it more
details more welcome if not we can move
on
need to take you just take this and this
just coming next
no desu
yeah good job everybody okay it's white
to move this one is also pretty cool so
the way to think about it is first of
all see what's the problem
and as soon as you see what is the
problem right now
then figure out the best way to distract
the piece that's causing you the problem
basically
yeah we have a bunch of people finding
it's good job so you see the problem is
that you want to take the queen but your
back rank is weak so this is a piece
that's causing you problems so you
distract the piece and astronauts take
you take back and next move you're doing
this and creating a new queen so yeah
good job
why to move again
sorry
okay we have a bunch of people finding
it perfect yeah
Benjamin Walmer good job also Paul also
other people who saw it but I just don't
need them sorry okay yeah good job so
basically after take the King has to
take back Bishop c5 you're kind of
suffocating the king or putting the king
in a corner or whatever metaphor you
want to use and then the next movie
Kate's roommate is inevitable this one
is white to move
yeah cool so many people found it so how
does manage seven work well see if you
take it I just take this guy and I'm
most likely going to win this end game
it's gotta be hard but it's at least
more winnable than this situation and if
after 97 you take this I take back with
the check and then I take it yeah and if
you do anything else I'm basically gonna
take your pieces so this one is black
stuff
yeah so many people found it cool so
yeah basically you do this check and the
idea is take check Nate's perfect so
what about this one
so I'm getting 9f trees but please
continue
so tell me 9f tree at what if I have to
take or not take
well it's not made because after night
if gf3 queen g3 king of uncleanness tree
there's wreckage to
mmm okay so the first move we agree but
the second move yes yeah Paul just said
it
you're good policy rating okay so
basically whatever why it does right now
if Y takes a with white goes away or g3
if I takes again with g3 and this is
winning so cool next one this is white
enough
so it's good that you're thinking about
checks but Chang is not the most
accurate move here unfortunately
so I think you are mainly thinking about
material when you should be thinking
about how the King is so ready to be
mated so yeah you want to play rickets
tree but right now you can't because of
the bishop on c8 so the same way that in
another puzzle you did that Queen a8 to
distract the rock on d8 for those of you
remember so think about a move to try
and distract the piece that's defending
yes so I got one correct answer so far
that I know
yes Joseph is right
yeah so I'm gonna show you because I
want to get through some more puzzles
but yeah so basically 97 is the right
one we were just trying to distract or
block I'll have to call it distracting
because it is kind of distracting the CH
bishop and the idea is that if you take
with anything besides the Bishop rook
history is made so you have sacred to
Bishop but now do you have enough time
to play rook F 3 and after rook F 3
depending on pretty much whatever black
does you are going to take this and if
Bishop takes back mate if King moves
away again mate so yeah pretty cool this
one is also white to move this is a game
by Petrosyan I'm assuming the world
champion because the New Age also
matches the year
oops
hmm NACA interference mr. acting
interference
[Music]
so it's almost the same idea of
interference distraction whatever you
want cut because so ideally you would
want to play root key five inmates but
you can't do that right now because the
bishop on d4 is defending it
so Suresh and Paul and I'm assuming a
bunch of other people found it and yeah
so you got you take on d4 the idea is
that with whatever it takes check and
then mate cool this one is also white to
move
Thank You Nick Ford English lessons I
really don't know their names I just
call them this direction
I think I have my first correct response
well I mean it's Islands why wouldn't
you say it's right
me huh no doubt all right
so yeah for those of you who are trying
to figure out which move to think about
first always think about checks just
does it even as a glance just to note
that they're there and what ideas do
they hold so yeah look at five and the
idea is you kind of have to take it then
you get to check he can only go one
place and then the night finishes the
job great let's do one more this one is
oh yeah it's a good one so keep thinking
about checks and if the checks are work
then takes if it takes some work then
the moves with threads
so I'm saying different ideas which
seems like they are all connected so
instead of giving me just the first move
give me more yeah okay Paul you're right
I mean you typed wrong what's your
rights okay now you got it
so yeah for those of you who are
thinking about the shuttle 5 first I
think that that would work but Bishop f5
unfortunately gives the move g6 to black
so it's easier instead of giving your
opponent chances to try and block g6 is
much more forcing so you just play g6 if
King g6 Bishop f5
if King h6 what if King h6 cuz whoops
if g6 we sell it take check mate so what
about just move just King moves
so hmm I don't know I don't want to so
I'm getting at five ideas but I don't
want to play effort because if you put
f5 here it kind of looks well I kind of
gave it away but if you put f5 thinking
has this square to go so that's why I
wouldn't want to play that and yeah just
just oh my god why can't I play Bishop
there we go
just this wins because if you take now I
can give you check and it's kind of neat
because just six pawn is protected so
like you all have the right idea you
wanted to defend the g6 wanted to
checkmate but the shovel 5 is more
accurate and fun fact so this is a game
by you so cough and in the game he
didn't play g6 heap simply played rook
t8 which is a still holds advantage but
the problem is that gives the opponent's
room to breathe with g6 and then like
rook at six and this not made anymore so
yeah
let's see should you do one more or you
want to call it a day
hmm let's see maybe one more yeah this
one is not that hard let's do one more
oh wait Palmer's bar see Wow
oh come on Paul is the last one and
Brian Clark got it yeah
okay so basically you give this check if
you run away just say thank you and if
take night that's pretty cool huh well I
do have more puzzles but that's all the
time I have for tonight
I hope you guys enjoyed it and yeah
doing these puzzles are kind of fun so
until next time
[Music]
you
[Music]